good guys do not get enough credit
so I'm gonna give you a list of green flags in guys
starting off with number one if he's nice to his mom or sister
that is a huge huge green flag
you wanna know why
because the way he treats his sister or mom relatives that are female
will show a lot about how he'll end up treating you
good men respect their sisters, moms
any female family member
the way he treats them is how he'll treat you
so huge green flag if he's nice to them
No.2 if his best friend is a guy not a female
no guys should ever have a girl best friend
it's just not possible argue all you want
but it's just not
Most woman would never date a man who has girl best friend
So huge green flag if he has a guy best friend
3 if he wears a watch and it's not digital
he's checking the time and going like this
and he can read from an analog watch
huge green flag
It gives me the sense that you're a mature grown man
and you're probably a good one
4 if he works out legs huge green flag
now he doesn't have to go crazy but at least incorporating them
once a week, if he hits all muscle groups
this shows that he's well rounded
that's a huge green flag
5 if he doesn't have a lot of followers on Instagram Snapchat
he doesn't care about that
bonus points if he doesn't have it at all
huge green flag
You should keep them forever
Here are all the green flags in men
Good men do not get enough credit
so if you're a man and you do any of these things or some of these things
Know that we as women
appreciate you for doing them